bio informatics for procedure oncology
is an online training program that is
going to cover a number of topics
related to precision oncology we will
explore how next-generation sequencing
including genomic mutations and gene
expression profiling are being utilized
in oncology research today many of these
techniques rely on bioinformatics so we
will explore how this program can help
anyone developed an independent project
in a fully online environment we will be
meeting bi-weekly every Monday and
Thursday the meetings will be online and
will last about an hour and the program
will last between June 10th and August
30th in 2019 our program speakers and
trainers include experienced
bioinformaticians as well as biologists
that have been conducting research for a
number of years they will introduce the
topics and cover the hands-on component
of every aspect so that it will be easy
to follow for a novice and expert alike
our first session will be dedicated to
the introduction to precision oncology
in this session we will talk about how
cancer occurs which biological changes
in organs tissues and cells cause cancer
and how cancer develops will also
discuss molecular factors in tumor
development and growth and metastasis we
will take a look at how clinical and
molecular data can be combined to really
understand this complex disease then we
will talk about the big data
bioinformatics how big data and
bioinformatics methods have made the
statistical approach to the analysis of
molecular data different we will talk
about the transition between hypothesis
testing which is a guided or supervised
type of analysis to data mining an
unsupervised type of analysis we will
also talk about very statistical aspects
and algorithmic aspects of analysis and
the different approaches to the
challenges that big data
and we'll also learn about the tee
violin for platform environment where we
will take various methods that require a
long time to run and also a long time to
design to run on your own computer that
way anyone even a novice can use the
point-and-click interface and understand
the logic of how these methods work
together to produce the desired result
we will also talk about the processing
of data identification of germline and
somatic mutations from genomic or DNA
data we'll also talk about the analysis
of this initial process data to
accurately detect variants and then we
will talk about interpretation how to
detect driver mutations oncogenes and
how to compile this information from the
whole genome we will also look at the
gene expression profiling how the
message of processing such as mapping
and quantification analysis such as
differential gene expression factor
regression analysis and others as well
as interpretation using gene ontology x'
and gene sets like pathways could be
used to really understand the biology of
a given sample we will also cover data
sources and databases taking a look at
NCBI repositories like TCGA and
reference databases compiled by
organizations like the National Cancer
Institute or cosmic finally we will talk
about some of the open questions and
some of the ways projects in
bioinformatics are typically designed
and how those projects could be compiled
into a proposal we will talk about
scientific inquiry and translational
value various aspects of cancer and look
at several examples including breast
cancer and liver cancer we are excited
to announce the registration for
introduction to precision oncology
starting immediately our program
speakers include Justin door who holds a
PhD in molecular biology from Brandeis
University as well as ProTeam
Chakraborty
who has a PhD in bioinformatics Sahil
Sethi who holds a master's degree in
biomedical informatics and we'll heat
Mazumdar who holds a PhD in
computational biology throughout this
program we will also rely on resources
available on the educational tion for
platform it will go together through
some of the basic courses like
introduction to bioinformatics
transcriptomics 1 in genomics 1 and look
at some of the projects that are
available for oncology research projects
like modeling cancer precision medicine
or a look at exercise in the DCIS
exosomes early stage breast cancer
biomarkers throughout the program all
the participants will have access to the
T bio info platform that combines easy
processing of data as well as analysis
visualization and interpretation at the
end of the program all of the
participants will get a certificate of
participation the program costs 135
dollars and will last for two and a half
months this includes a three months
training program hands-on analysis
practice one on one question answer
sessions as well as assistance 5
terabytes of data storage in a 14-day
account on T bio info you can register
at the link below
edu T bio infocomm forward slash
precision - oncology